neue gewalt in hongkong
die polizei kesselte protestierende
studenten an der uni ein
der ausgang ist ungewiss gemeinsamer
appell wirtschaft und gewerkschaften
fordern mehr staatliche investitionen
deutschland müsse wettbewerbsfähig
bleiben lawinen und hochwasser in
österreich kämpfen viele regionen mit
den folgen von jeder menge schnee und
starkregen
die nachrichten nicht dass heute mit
christian sieber und abend hinein an
diesem montag um sieben ihre
nachrichtenüberblick mit dem sport
natürlich auch später in der sendung und
kristin otto sehr gerne guten abend wir
beginnen mit der aktuellen situation in
hongkong die sich immer mehr zuspitzt
das war wieder eine nacht mit heftigen
protesten und viel gewalt auf beiden
seiten
brennpunkt ist eine universität wo die
polizei demonstrierende studenten
eingekesselt hat tränengas einsetzt und
schlagstöcke und jeden der raus will
festnimmt
die lage ist dermaßen eskaliert dass die
frage immer drängender wird kann es noch
einen ausweg geben stefanie schöneborn
berichtet noch immer ist die universität
in hongkong besetzt einige hundert
protestler sind es noch draußen hat die
polizei alles hermetisch abgeriegelt
niemand kommt mehr rein vor allem aber
nicht raus den ganzen morgen lang
versuchen radikale protestler die
universität zu verlassen
doch die polizei jagt sie mit tränengas
wieder zurück in das gebäude
oder nimmt einen nach dem anderen lässt
mehr als 150 festnahmen gab es in den
letzten zwei tagen
ich formuliere eine klare warnung an die
aus purer testet nicht unsere grenzen
wenn wir wirklich angemessen reagieren
dann ist unsere einzige option von
tödlichen waffen gebrauch zu machen
viele schreckt die drohungen nicht den
ganzen tag über formieren sich hilfs
ketten mit freiwilligen die verpflegung
zur universität bringen wollen
am frühen abend versuchen tausende
menschen zu der universität zu gelangen
da mischen sich radikale frontline mit
friedlichen demonstranten der laufen
alte und junge miteinander
sie alle wollen die eingekesselten
protestler unterstützen und kommen nicht
weiter wichtig vor allem heute sind
vorwiegend die regenschirme zurück das
symbol für den friedlichen protest
weniger fliegende brandsätze als in der
letzten nacht es ist die masse der
menschen mit der die polizei diese nacht
vor allem zu kämpfen hat die meisten
demonstranten hier sind eltern
büroangestellte die der regierung zeigen
dass sie auch noch da sind sagte noch
nach bei unserer korrespondentin
stephanie haben die demonstrierenden
studenten mit ihren aktionen immer noch
die millionen zahl von hongkongs bürgern
hinter sich die wir ja im sommer gesehen
haben auf den straßen
sie haben auf jeden fall die solidarität
die solidarität ist da und sie war
eigentlich auch nie wirklich wirklich
weg sie wurde heute abend noch mal laut
in form der proteste auf die straße
getragen es war nicht millionen die da
unterwegs waren
aber was wir gesehen haben ist dass die
solidarität mit diesen 400 radikalen
protestlern obwohl radikal immer noch
sehr groß war
denn die vorstellung dass sie dort
festgehalten werden und der polizei
ausgesetzt sind das hat die menschen
eindeutig wieder zusammengeführt
jetzt erleben wir ja dass die lage immer
brenzliger wird ist denn irgendwie ein
ausweg zu sehen oder steuert das in
hongkong jetzt geradewegs auf eine
katastrophe zu was auffällig ist ist das
schweigen der regierungschefin carol m
von der hat man in den letzten tagen
eigentlich so gut wie gar nichts gehört
dafür war die hongkonger polizei
umso präsenter in form von drohungen und
taten wie man die ganze das ganze
wochenende schon gesehen hat die frage
ist die strategie der polizei scheint so
zu sein dass sie die radikalen
protestler von den friedlichen
demonstranten trennen will
wie wir heute gesehen haben geht diese
strategie nicht so ganz auf und trotzdem
glaube ich werden sie genau daran
festhalten denn ich halte es immerhin
auch für sehr unwahrscheinlich dass die
hong kong regierung wirklich die um die
hilfe der chinesischen volksarmee bittet
denn das würde vermutlich tatsächlich in
einer katastrophe enden
stefanie schöneborn herzlichen dank und
wir bitten die nicht ganz optimale
bildqualität zu entschuldigen so viel zu
diesem thema zunächst jetzt nach
deutschland hier echt die infrastruktur
straßen handynetz die bahn auf der
anderen seite hält die bundesregierung
an der schwarzen
bild fest und möchte keine neuen
schulden machen die öffentlichen
investitionen lagen in deutschland 2017
bei 2,1 prozent der wirtschaftsleistung
das ist weniger als der eu durchschnitt
von 2,8 prozent und weit hinter
frankreich mit zuletzt 3,4 prozent heute
ganz ungewöhnlich ein gemeinsamer appell
von gewerkschaften und industrie nicole
diekmann das schienennetz der umstieg
auf elektroautos der bildungssektor
es soll endlich investiert werden in
deutschland denn das habe die grupo
verschlafen
ein vernichtendes urteil gefällt von
einer ungewöhnlichen allianz vertreter
von industrie und gewerkschaften wandten
sich heute an die bundesregierung
deutschland ist sich hatte dies an
anderer stelle so bezeichnet zum spaß
land geworden und es wird zeit wieder
aufzuwachen mindestens 450 milliarden
zusätzliche öffentliche investitionen
gestreckt auf die kommenden zehn jahre
so die forderung in konkreten zahlen
die menschen müssen vor ort in ihrem
alltag spüren und das die
lebensbedingungen sich verbessern dass
die zukunftsfähigkeit unseres landes
garantiert wird und dafür brauchen wir
eine investitionsoffensive die eine
aufbruchstimmung für eine gute zukunft
weg die linkspartei ungleich deutlicher
seefahrt einen kurswechsel angesichts
günstiger kredite in der zeit in der das
geld nichts kostet für den staat in dem
man sogar noch was dafür bekommt muss er
in die zukunft investieren und nicht in
so einem blödsinn wie schwarze null
machen
in meseberg aber zum abschluss der
kabinettsklausur klares nein von
finanzminister und der kanzlerin an der
schwarzen null gebe es nichts zu rütteln
für mich ist auch sehr wichtig dass wir
unsere gesamtverschuldung runter bringen
konnten jetzt wieder unter 60 prozent
und wir können mit
dieser haushaltspolitik auch wachstum
generieren und insofern ist das die
richtschnur
die kabinettsklausur ist nun vorbei die
debatte um den sparkurs aber ganz
bestimmt noch lange nicht beschlossen
hat die regierung das 1,1 milliarden
euro ins mobilfunknetz gesteckt werden
sollen vor allem für neue sendemasten
auf dem land und es gibt zwei wichtige
änderungen bei den sozialabgaben der
beitrag zur arbeitslosenversicherung
wird gesenkt ganz leicht um 0,1
prozentpunkt und nur befristet bis 2022
außerdem sollen ab dem nächsten jahr
menschen entlastet werden die
betriebsrenten bekommen sie müssen dann
erst ab einer betriebsrente von 159 euro
im monat beiträge zur krankenkasse
bezahlen
beispiel wer 169 euro betriebsrente pro
monat bekommt muss nur noch auf zehn
euro krankenkassenbeiträge zahlen
das wären dann etwa 1 euro 50 pro monat
im iran heute deutliche worte der
regierung an die eigene bevölkerung
erstens es müsse schluss sein mit gewalt
und vandalismus bei den demonstrationen
zweitens die benzinpreiserhöhungen die
die proteste ausgelöst haben bleiben
seit tagen gehen im iran menschen gegen
die neuen spritpreise und gegen die
regierung auf die strasse und zwar
landesweit da braut sich was zusammen
jörg brase berichtet nur wenige bilder
der proteste finden ihren weg hinaus in
die welt
das internet im iran ist seit samstag
abgeschaltet doch auch gestern und heute
gab es wieder demonstrationen gegen die
entscheidung den benzinpreis zu
verdreifachen
meine regierung wird es
selbstverständlich nicht zulassen dass
irgendjemand einen aufstand organisiert
oder unsicherheit schafft dennoch ist es
das recht der menschen zu protestieren
und unsere entscheidung zu kritisieren
irans sicherheitsbehörden drohten jeden
der gesetze verletzt habe zu finden und
zu bestrafen die wut in der bevölkerung
auf die hohen benzinpreise aber bleibt
das war eine völlig falsche entscheidung
ich stehe hier seit stunden und kann nur
drei liter tanken weil ich nicht genug
geld in der tasche haben
würden sie das geld benutzen um das land
aufzubauen wäre es okay aber sie werden
es nur ihren eigenen kindern im ausland
zu schieben
die religiösen hardliner kritisieren oft
die politik der regierung johanni als zu
liberal
irans religiöses oberhaupt aber stellte
sich überraschend hinter die
preiserhöhung liegt jedoch zur vorsicht
die autoritäten sollten versuchen die
folgen dieser maßnahme für die menschen
so gut es geht zu reduzieren sowie
harmonie verzichtete heute auch das
parlament auf jede kritik an rohan ihs
entscheidung
stattdessen schloss man die politischen
reihen wieder gegen den gemeinsamen
feind usa die amerikaner hieß es
versuchten das land durch die
wirtschaftssanktionen ins chaos zu
stürzen das regime in teheran ist
entschlossen auch diese protestwelle
wenn nötig mit gewalt zu stoppen
zurück nach deutschland auf
verkehrsminister andreas scheuer wächst
der druck wegen der gescheiterten
pkw-maut kritik kommt jetzt auch ganz
offiziell vom bundesrechnungshof scheuer
habe vergaberecht verletzt und gegen
haushaltsrecht verstoßen so steht das in
einem bericht der behörde
dem bund drohen schadenersatzzahlungen
in millionenhöhe nachdem der europäische
gerichtshof die maut für rechtswidrig
erklärt hatte da hatte das
verkehrsministerium die verträge aber
schon längst geschlossen
in brandenburg haben die grünen den weg
für eine neue regierung mit spd und cdu
frei gemacht in einer urabstimmung unter
den parteimitgliedern sprachen sich 90,8
prozent für den neuen koalitionsvertrag
aus schon morgen wollen spd cdu und
grüne ihre künftige koalition besiegelt
ein großes versprechen der
weltgemeinschaft vor ziemlich genau 30
jahren im november 1989 haben die
vereinten nationen die
kinderrechtskonvention verabschiedet und
seitdem gab es große erfolge die
kindersterblichkeit ist weltweit um etwa
60 prozent gesunken und doch warnt das
kinderhilfswerk unicef ein viertel aller
kinder auf der welt wächst den ländern
auf in denen sie durch
konflikte und naturkatastrophen in
höchster gefahr sind
mehr jetzt von romanesco war 30 jahre
kinderrechtskonvention für unicef ein
meilenstein der zugang zu bildung hat
sich in afrika und asien deutlich
verbessert trotzdem besuchen immer noch
millionen jungen und mädchen nicht mal
die grundschule zur pressekonferenz ist
felix bender gekommen
der 17 jährige geht in malawi zur schule
was heißt lernen unter extrembedingungen
eine grundschulklasse bei uns bedeutet
bis zu 200 schüler die klassen sind
völlig überfüllt denn auf die 200
schüler kommt ein einziger lehrer
ähnlich die situation bei der
kindersterblichkeit sie geht zwar zurück
allerdings die staaten schaffen es nicht
das risiko für kinder aus armen und
wohlhabenden familien gleichermaßen zu
senken
bei der impfung ist es ähnlich ärmere
kinder haben oft keinen schutz vor
diphtherie tetanus und keuchhusten
erschwert wird die situation durch neue
probleme
allen voran durch den klimawandel schon
heute leben 160 millionen kinder in
dürregebieten für diese kinder für viele
andere kinder verschärft sich die
lebenssituation auch die digitalisierung
eine herausforderung gefahren wie
cybermobbing oder kinderpornographie
lauern
andererseits nutzer der nachwuchs das
netz positiv für seine eigenen anliegen
wir sehen dass kinder längst dabei sind
ihre stimme zu erheben dass sie sich zu
wichtigen zeitgenössischen themen wie
dem klimawandel und anderen themen
lautstark zu wort melden und wir sind
davon überzeugt dass die welt dadurch
einfach besser werden kann
so bleibt die bilanz von unicef
zwiespältig die junge generation zeigen
sich aktiv trotzdem 30 jahre nach
einführung der kinderrechte bleibt das
ziel chancengleichheit weltweit in
weiter ferne
und jetzt diese statistik
verpackungsmüll ist ein riesiges problem
und die letzten zahlen zeigen das
deutlich
im jahr 2017 vielen 18,7 millionen
tonnen in deutschland an
das macht 226,5 kilometer und damit noch
einmal drei prozent mehr als im jahr
davor
das hat das umweltbundesamt ausgerechnet
der grund liegt im konsumverhalten jedes
einzelnen mehr online bestellungen
kleinere verpackungsgrößen vor allem der
trend zu essen und trinken to go in
pappbechern oder plastik schachtel in
südfrankreich ist eine autobrücke
eingestürzt eine 15 jährige kam ums
leben mehrere menschen wurden verletzt
die 150 meter lange hängebrücke führt
über einen fluss bei toulouse mindestens
ein auto und ein lastwagen stürzte ins
wasser
die suche nach vermissten läuft noch die
brücke galt nicht als
sanierungsbedürftig französische medien
berichten dass der laster schwerer
gewesen sein könnte als auf der brücke
erlaubt es schneit und regnet immer
weiter in österreich hochwasser und
lawinen sorgen für große probleme zum
beispiel in kärnten
dort kam ein mann bei einem erdrutsch
ums leben eine schlammlawine begrub im
bundesland salzburg zwei häuser noch
immer sind einige orte von der außenwelt
abgeschnitten weil straßen unpassierbar
sind und es soll weiter regnen und
schneien
britta hilpert in bad kleinkirchheim in
kärnten förderte österreichs
extremwetter das erste todesopfer
eine mure erfasste einen rentner als er
im garten nach dem rechten sehen wollte
sechs häuser wurden vorsorglich allein
hier evakuiert doch in vielen teilen des
südlichen österreichs sorgt die masse an
niederschlägen für zahlreiche
straßensperrungen gleis unterspülungen
lebens gefahren in bad gastein traf
einer der zahlreichen abgänge ein haus
das ich dann über ein weiteres haus
schob noch in der nacht konnten zwei
frauen geborgen werden verletzt
aber lebend es war unter schwerste
gearbeitet weil die nummer noch kommen
über den weg laufen müssen und die
frauen haben einen schweren also ist es
für dich
das war als damals im martelltal in
südtirol quetschte sich gestern eine
lawine durch den ort verletzt wurde
niemand aber die aufräumarbeiten sind
beträchtlich weiter oben in den bergen
versperren lawinenabgänge den zugang zu
einigen gemeinden in pregarten sogar
schon seit tagen und so wird es hier
langsam knapp wenn sie einen mangel an
lebensmittel und betriebsmittel haben
werden und da auch ich schon die bitte
rausgegangen an das land da kommt noch
mehr aus den bergen die flüsse im süden
österreich sind schon jetzt mehr als
randvoll
ab morgen regnet es mancherorts wieder
das wetter bei uns kommt gleich erst
haben wir den sport christus von einer
nationalmannschaft stürmer luca
waldschmidt wurde nach seiner mittel
gesichtsfraktur heute operiert seine
ausfallzeit bleibt aber auch wegen
seiner weiteren verletzungen an knie und
sprunggelenk ungewiss im morgigen em
quali spiel gegen nordirland wird es
noch mehr personelle veränderungen geben
beim letzten auftrag 2009/10 lässt läuft
links verteidiger hector nach fast einem
jahr wieder spielen
im mittelfeld werden erneut groß kimmig
und gündogan die schaltzentrale bilden
der bundestrainer will ein kompliziertes
jahr positiv zu ende bringen was ich
unser ziel wir wollen das nächste spiel
gegen nordirland gewinne
wir wollen die gruppe vor holland
abschließend das wäre schön
löw lobte heute sein team liegt aber
vorsichtig optimistisch auf die euro als
favorit bei diesem turnier sehe ich uns
nicht allerdings ist klar natürlich
werden wir alles versuchen dass man auch
in dem turnier das maximum auch
erreichen wollen klar das ziel ein
erfolg morgen und mit energie ins em
jahr starten
zwei neue trainer verpflichtungen im
keller der bundesliga bei mainz 05
unterschrieb achim beierlorzer gerade
mal neun tage nach seiner entlassung
beim ersten fc köln und die geißböcke
wollten als dessen nachfolger markus
gisdol sowie horst heldt als neuen
sportchef und noch zur formel1
alarmstufe rot bei ferrari nach dem
gestrigen crash der beiden stallrivalen
vettel und le claire beim vorletzten
wm-lauf in sao paulo
italiens sport presse schreibt heute von
einem albtraum ferraris vom doppelten
eigentor wenige runden vor schluss
kollidieren liegend sebastian vettel und
schale claire im kampf um platz 4 das
aus für beide
ein super gau ferrari-teamchef binotto
hält sich mit schuldzuweisungen noch
zurück in einem aber sind sich alle
einig ein paar pünktchen mit nach hause
zu nehmen wäre klüger gewesen als
auszufliegen ob vettel zu früh nach
innen zog will ferrari in ruhe klären
das er und legt er nicht zum ersten mal
aneinander gerieten macht schon jetzt
nachdenklich die beiden piloten sind gut
aber man sieht dass sie nicht
miteinander klar kommen vielleicht ganz
gut dass diese so bald vorbei ist
in zwei wochen finale in abu dhabi
christian vielen dank
beim wetter hat gunter czisch schnee im
angebot wo genau sagte ihnen gleich
selbst das heute journal mit dem
kollegen claus kleber gegen viertel nach
zehn von uns danke für heute gern bis
morgen und in allen ein angenehm
montagabend
[Musik]
und da am liebe zuschauer das extreme
wetter in den alpen geht noch weiter
großräumig tauscht sich derzeit die luft
aus über dem atlantik fließt kaltluft
von norden weit in den süden nach
portugal und spanien hier vom mittelmeer
über osteuropa die warmluft nach norden
und an der alpensüdseite staut sich
dagegen unter schnee extrem wetter
während es bei uns morgen mal meist
trocken wird aber heute nacht nicht
haben wir den kräftigen regen im
nordwesten schnee im sauerland und in
der eifel
oberhalb von 400 meter ist es stürmische
norddeutschland im süden ist es ruhiger
da kriegen wir dann den frost zum teil 0
bis minus 3 grad aber frostfrei bleibt
zu norden und an den küsten wird zum
morgen anfangs noch regnen das lästern
am nachmittag doch mehr und mehr nach es
kann sturmböen geben aus dem südwesten
an der ostsee ansonsten kommt hier
norddeutschland auch mal die sonne raus
auch in süddeutschland ist das möglich
vornehmen bayern wieder aber ansonsten
bleibt es doch meist grau dabei aber es
ist wenigstens trocken und die
temperaturen erreichen meist so zwischen
5 und 10 grad 3 kart sind es an den
alten die aussichten temperaturen
bleiben so bei den werten es wird dann
meist trockener aber donnerstag wird es
im osten nur norden noch mal regnen
ich wünsche einen schönen abend und
macht es gut